Street oh yeah are you doing I'm good
how are you oh man I'm gonna get right
into it I am a fitness nut oh yeah dude
this this is not me believe all right
that's the size of my head I am
developing a whole protein shake I think
would work for everyone I just want you
to taste it and see if it's going to
work okay and I'm when I'm not mad at it
yeah okay it does just straight-up taste
like a chocolate oh it is really good
yes that's the best protein in the world
is there any working oh it's uh normally
good I feel like there's something crazy
it is mmm but it tastes like a malted
milkshake yeah well you want to know
what the secret ingredient is scariest
oh god I I don't know if I want to know
no I
I need a I know other day why hmm
no they're already blended up what's in
there crickets
listen man dude those are the bugs the
crickets no they're not bugs it's
crickets curious how could you do this
to me you know what do you mean huh
listen I'm sleeping with you babe
okay here's wait wait now that I know
what is okay I got a little egg in my
teeth if you get past the stigma you
know how many people you could feed in
the world we just solved the world no
products Oh
oh no I have no idea I'm just kidding
no I'm not really I'm not really selling
this protein at all these are real
crickets well yeah there are crickets in
there there really is
it's just not okay what if supported the
product but I've got mom oh my god on a
TV thank you no - you know - yeah how
the bomb